Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie
Ajourd'hui on se retrouve pour la suite de Youtubers Life
Parce qu'on a une youtubeuse à faire devenir numéro un ...
Mondial !
Bah ouais les décolletés n'ont pas suffit
Les titres en majuscule n'ont pas suffit non plus
Alors on va essayer de trouve un autre truc
N'oubliez pas l'objectif : le million d'euro
Pas d'abonnés *rire*
Là, attention ça ne blague plus
On va chercher un appart' pour être en coloc', mon gars
Il faut 160$ et on peut partir vivre en colocation avec un poto à nous !
Ooooooh ! Mon dieu
C'est exceptionnel ce qu'il ce passe !
'Tain regardez ce beau bureau !
On va pouvoir faire des vidéos trop biens !
Donc là apparemment améliorer nos skill grâce à cette nouvelle bibliothèque
Ikéa, on va pas se mentir
Regardez putain, c'est bon ça
Ça coûte de la tune
D'accord, donc en fait, tout... On se ruine !
On se ruine, j'aurais jamais dû emménager
Allez on va se faire une petite vidéo gaming
"Cliquez et je vous paye", voilà
On est pas du tout désespérés.
Allez on met la vidéo en ligne
Ah, ça, alors ça c'est mon coloc', c'est ça ?
Allez on lui fat un calin
On te fait un calin
Il nous a repoussé ?
Je vais te tuer
Allez on continue, on fait des vidéos là, pour le kiffe... pour l'argent
On va pas se mentir, on a plein de trucs à payer les gars
Je suis désolé, un moment, on va charbonner, on va charbonner hein
Allez hop, nouvelle vidéo GamePlay
On fait que ça
Chaque nouvelle vidéo c'est su le même jeu à chaque fois
C'est même la même vidéo
Cyprien, Norman, Natoo, Andy : le clash
Ça fera des vus
On va travailler pendant que ça upload mec
C'est une super idé
8 Heures ! 40$
Mais allez !
Alors ça c'est une notion que j'avais pas vu dans l'épisode d'avant
C'est pour ça qu'on était tout l temps en dèche de tune
C'est qu'on peut aller travailler
Voilà
On va à Picard, on vend nos petits surgelés
On revient, on peut s'acheter un jeu et faire de meilleures vidéos
Super !
Allez, rendu en cours
On mange un petit sandwich et on va travailler
On va charbonner
On a des rêves pleins la tête
Des envies pleins les yeux
Des poils pleins les aisselles
C'est nul
Oh non, on vient de perdre tous nos abonnés suite à cette blague
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on va faire maintenant
La vidéo buzz pas trop trop
Ça c'est ma ma coloc'
Elle m'a invité à voir un flm
Bon allez, allez, allez
On a le droit à un petit plaisir en tant que youtuber
Regardez, elle rigole, elle a l'air heureuse d'y aller
C'est mort ! Tu fais des vus, tu fais de la tune !
Non merci
Dégage
Tu charbonnes !
Go shopping, on va s'acheter le nouveau jeu tendance qui buzz
Ça, ça vient de sortir ça
"Undead" machin
On le commande !
Alors, faut qu'on fasse une vidéo sur "Heavy Hair Salon Kingdom"
C'est un poto qui veut qu'on fasse ça
C'est sur Z-Box
Putain ça va être cher
Faut réparer le PC parce que l'autre elle vient de l'utiliser, elle l'a pété sale pute !
J't'ai dit de pas aller sur le sites porno y a des spams horribles
Bon du coup on va dormir pendant qu'il le répare
Allez, on lui fait confiance
Y va rien voler, y a rien à voler mec
Ok, on a dormit, il s'est barré
C'est marrant c'est qu'on a dormit vraiment une seconde si on regarde bien
La sieste la plus courte du monde
Il y a une rumeur disant que tu fais que des vidéos pour l'argent
Nan
Non, non, non oh non !
Ils m'ont grillé !
C'est faux, on fait ça par passion
Hervé, cache tout les tableaux qui valent des millions
Je pense qu'il serait mieux d'ignorer ces rumeurs de merde
Ouais, ouais, ouais
Mais c'est mort, allez d'où tu penses ça
Je refuse que des gens pensent ça
Oh bah regardez, j'ai été sincère, mes abonnés ont kiffé et je suis contente, super
On va dormir, manger, charbonner, et acheter la Z-Box allez
Voyez, on a pris un max de skill n'empêche pour mettre des vidéos
On fait des super vidéos là
Est-ce que tu veux chatter
Bah non, mais à chaque ...
Le mec il me demande de chatter au moment où je lance le rendu de ma vidéo
T'es super chiant Éric
Je peux pas chatter avec toi, le PC est occupé ok
Et faire de l'argent est plus important que tes cheveux verts batard
'Tain j'espère vraiment qu'y pas des gens qui vont prendre exemple sur ce jeu pour faire des vidéos putain
Alors, nouveau jeu, le 28 février
"Samurai spelling" c'est super ça
50$ Putain !
On demande à l'éditeur de nous l'envoyer
Allez, on pèse dans notre appart' et tout
20 mille abonnés s'te plaît
J'attends le colis et on fait direct une vidéo dessus
Direct !
Il est là, c'est parti
First impression, parce qu'il vient de sortir
Alors là, mec ça va cartonner
On annonce la couleur
Buzz mondial en vue
Éric qui veut chatter
Mais , mais c'est un sketch
Éric au cheveux verts, je sais pas change d'horaire mec
Tu veux un rencard avec moi et mes gros seins ou pas ?
Alors contact-moi à ne autre heure
Alors y a une meuf qui nous propose 240$ pour euh
On accepte, on sait pas ce qu'elle veut mis on accepte
On a reçu le jeu
On dort, on fait la vidéo sur le jeu
pour les 240$, putain mec
Ola ola, avec la tune qu'on a !
J'ai envie de pleurer
On va faire la vidéo sur ce jeu
Vidéo sponsorisée,
je suis honnête donc liker la vidéo
Putain, buzz mondial en vu ! 50 mille vues ! Mais mec
Mais mec
Mec, notre vie, on a un tournant dans notre vie là
On a bientôt les 50 milles abonnés
On va bientôt pouvoir acheter une villa et acheter un chef cuisto
On va dormir
La vidéo sponso est en ligne
Du coup on va toucher beaucoup d'argent
Amazing
Attend, est-ce qu'il faut pas mieux acheter du matos pour améliorer la qualité nos vidéos ?
PC World
Mec on va se prendre un PC Gamer !
Ah, c'est cher ! Ah ça pique !
Bon dans le doute on se prend celui-là
Putain mec, on se commande un PC
Là on a le nouveau PC
Incoryable
Oh non, non
Des problèmes de droit d'auteur sur nos vidéos
'Tain si la chaîne est striker, on pourra plus gagner d'argent grâce à nos vid...
Euh, on pourra plus faire des vidéos parce qu'on aime ça
Ok, ok, on va résoudre ce problème
Va falloir supprimer la vidéo c'st ça ?
Bah on la supprime, on la supprime
Voilà
Faut qu'on en refasse une, sinon les abonnés ils vont nous faire la gueule
Putain !
C'est pas grave, on va revenir en force avec une vidéo exclusive sur une console qu'on avait pas
On va prendre la Honey PlayStudios
Clac
Et y a un nouveau jeu qui vient de sortir
Je l'ai pas prise pour rien
Qui s'appelle "Honey PlayStudios" je sais pas quoi
Est-ce qu'on a assez, oui
Ola ola lala, le buzz
Ok, la console est là ! Amazing
Et le jeu, le jeu, le jeu
Ok super
Première impression, parce qu'il vient de sortir
Ah non, il est sorti
MErde, je me suis trompé de jeu
J'en ai pris un qui est sorti y a longtemps.
Oh le con
Éric qui veut chatter au moment où on upload la vidéo
Éric, je suis désolé, je suis désolé, au revoir
Oh oui, on a une requête
Une petite vidéo sponso' nous ferait du bien là
Il nous faut une vidéo de "Kamikaze Bowling" sur la "NicoSoft zBox"
Oh je m'en bats les couilles, on bosse comme un fils de chien, on se l'achète
Invitation à un évènement
Ok on est entrain de s'habiller pour aller à cette fameuse présentation
En espérant qu'il y est des youtubers
Bravo
Ah ! Voilà une petite réunion de l'après-show
On va pouvoir parler à des youtubers
Je veux être seul actuellement, ne me fait pas chier
Oh la gros tête, le gros tête ça y est
Allez, je me battre d'ici, ça craint
C'est pas tout mais on a des vidéos à faire nous
Ok alors, nouvelle webcam
Nouveau microphone
What's up Squeezette, on a un fête ce soir
Bon ok, ok
Ok
allez, allez, on l'a bien mérité, mec
Allez on retourne au travail, faut charbonner
Allez c'est parti
Nouvelle vidéo, mon gars, on va tout défoncer
Objectif 8 Millions de vues ! Partagerais l'argent avec vous
chers abonnés, parce que je vous aime
Voilà, finalement écrire un livre plutôt que de faire un titre aussi long
On peut le faire, on peut le faire, vas-y
On peut le faire, on peut le faire
Champagne, c'est parti, 50 mille abonnés Wouhou
Je fais un Give way, parce que j'adore mes abonnés
Je fais gagner cette figurine en plastique d'une valeur de 6€
Faite pas vos putes, c'est déjà bien une figurine en plastique
J'aurais pu faire gagner une plante
Les amis, 50 milles abonnés c'est quoi ?
C'est un nouveau style vestimantraire
Ok on est sur Asos.fr
On va prendre
Oh bah ça c'est très bien
Body fitness for female, mais c'est super ça
Les gens vont adorer bordel.
Y a pas un petit short là ?
Un tout petit short, une petite jupette, une petite jupette
Mini skirt for female, on la prend
En chaussure qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
On a pas des petites chaussures à talons ?
Des tongs, mais c'est bien ça
Ça va plaire aux hommes
Les petites lunettes rondes je les aime bien moi
Un petit foulard rouge, c'est mignon
Alors là, comment on s'est refait mon gars
C'est la première fois qu'on achète des vêtements en 6 ans
On a le temps de faire une petite vidéo en attendant, on va pas se mentir
"En attendant ma commande asos", voilà
Eh bah ouais, nous on est dans une relation de sincérité avec nos abonnés, faut pas l'oublier
Hop
Oh mon dieu, avec les tongs, putain c'est beau
Ola lala, qu'on est beau
Ce jour est enfin arrivé
C'est une nouvelle vie qui s'offre à nous
Tellement une nouvelle vie qu'on va changer d'appartement !
On va partir sur un 2 pièces
On doit choisir si notre colocataire vient ou pas avec nous
On fait route seule bro, désolé
Oooh
Mon
Dieu
Attends il est super bien cet apprat'
Hyper lumineux, vraiment un F2 de qualité
En plus on l'a loué meublé, à mon avis
Maintenant qu'on est dans ce nouvel appart, notre objectif c'st de trouver un collaborateur
Qui pourra faire des vidéos pour notre chaîne Youtube
Dafuq ?
Donc faudrait qu'on aille à un évènement où y a plein de youtubeur pour en chopper un comme ça
Mais attends je suis débile sinon, on a des potos
Elle !
On peut l'inviter
Vient à la maison
On va parler à Ashley
On va l'inviter
Work contract
On l'emploie
Ça y est, elle est là
On va lui demander de faire des vidéos
C'est hyper glauque putain
On emploie des esclaves
On veut de la tune
Elle va faire des vidéos à ma place
Mais mec c'est glauque de ouf
La passion est là quoi putain
Elle a intérêt à bosser, puisque mec, apparemment on la paye méga cher quoi
Ok elle se met à travailler
C'est bon ça
Alors elle a fait la vidéo, maintenant on décide si on l'upload ou pas
Oh ouais, elle a fait un truc super
C'est très bien, on upload
"Game Over"
Pourquoi game over ?
Pourquoi game over, expliquait-moi j'ai fait une vidéo tellement merdique que je suis éliminé c'est ça ?
Youtube me ban ?
C'est quoi ce bordel mon gars ?